what i want to do in this video is
hopefully give more intuition as to why
the binomial theorem or the binomial
formula involves combinatorics so let's
just think about what this expansion
would be so i'm just using a particular
example that's pretty simple x plus y to
the third power which is x plus y times
x plus y times x plus y so we already
know what the terms look like we could
pick an x from each of these so if we
pick exactly an x from each of these
that's going to be our x to the third
term and it's going to be and we
essentially picked no y's then because
we picked an x from each of these when
we multiplied out to get this term and
how many ways are there to construct
that how many ways are there if we're
picking from three things
so we're taking we're picking from three
things how many ways can we choose
exactly zero y's of not picking a y well
there's only one way to do that there's
only one possible way of doing that by
taking and by not picking a y from each
of them or you could say by picking an x
from each of them so the coefficient
right over here is 1 x to the third
there's only one way when you take this
product out only one of the terms
initially is going to have an x to the
third in it
now what about the next term so plus
so what if we're now we're going to pick
from three buckets but we're going to we
want to pick one y so another way of
thinking about it you have three people
or we have three people
this person this person and this person
and one of them you're going to choose
to be uh to i guess you know be your
friend that's another way of saying
which of these are you going to pick the
y from so
this is this is the exact same thing as
the combinatorics problem
from three things
from three things you are choosing one
of them to be y and of course three
choose one this is equal to three and so
if you're if you're picking one y that
means you're picking two x's so and
you're taking the product of everything
so it's x squared times
y to the one and we could keep doing
that logic so plus
so now we're going to think about the
situation where we are picking
two y's out of three things so it's x to
the first
y
squared so we're starting with three
things and we're going to pick two to
two of these y's so it could be this y
and this y
to take the product to
construct the product y squared so it
could be y times y times that x
or it could be it could be y times y
times that x
or it could be y times x times y so this
is three choose two so out of three
things what are the different ways what
are the combinations of picking two
things if you have three friends how
many combinations can you put two of
them in your two-seater car where you
don't care about who sits in which seat
you're just thinking about how many
different combinations can you pick from
that and once again this evaluates two 3
and then finally how many different ways
how many different ways
from a set of three things
from three different things so from each
of these expressions how many ways can
you pick exactly three y's well there's
only one way to do it you pick this y
this y and that y and so if you're
picking three y's that means you picked
zero x's and you have picked three y's
so that's why we're dealing with
combinatorics here three choose three
from uh from three expressions your
three binomials right over here that you
are taking the product from you're
choosing you you need to choose three
y's so you have to pick the second term
in all of them there's only one way to
do that here you want to pick the second
term the y term in two of them exactly
two of them here you want to pick the y
term in exactly one of them there's one
way to do this three ways to do this
sorry there's three ways to do this
three ways to do this one way to do that
one way to do that so this
is one and this is three when you
evaluate
when you apply the formula for three
choose or you know n choose k
three and this is
one